ce comportement a insouciant et volage
du roi agace profondément sa mère Anne
d'Autriche qui ne va pas se priver de
lui dire
seulement la reine mère va bientôt le
regretter
le 9 mars 1661 Mazarin celui qui jusqu'à
présent gouvernait le pays aux côtés
pour Louis XIV qui peut désormais
prendre en main son destin de roi
dès le lendemain le 10 mars 1661 il
annonce à ses ministres et à sa mère
comment il entend à l'avenir gouverner
le pays seul en monarque absolue c'est
ce que l'histoire retiendra de lui
aujourd'hui la phase du théâtre change
jusqu'à ce jour j'ai laissé gouverner
mes affaires par mes ministres sous la
direction de feu le cardinal Mazarin
désormais j'aurais eu raison
seulement Anne d'Autriche sa mère ne
l'entend pas de cette oreille
c'est exactement ce que je compte faire
vous n'avez aucune expérience du pouvoir
la guitare oui
je décide je suis le roi j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour ma mère elle a
beaucoup fait pour moi je ne peux le
nier mais désormais il est temps qu'elle
me cède la place
Anne d'Autriche qui a du mal à voir son
fils grandir tente par tous les moyens
de le dissuader de gouverner seul
en vain
alors madame vous me forcerez à vous
exclure vous aussi
si ma mère pour le bien du royaume
d'ailleurs voilà c'est fait
désormais Anne d'Autriche n'a plus aucun
rôle politique elle se centrale
je suis très en colère j'ai tout fait
pour que mon fils devienne au plus grand
roi de France et voilà qui me congé dit
comme la dernière des malpropres je
trouve ça profondément injuste
ce jour-là Louis XIV devient le monarque
absolu que l'on connaît doté de tous les
pouvoirs
comme l'on dit il vient de couper le
cordon maternel mais il va se séparer de
sa mère
pas mal humilitarisme est presque
c'est-à-dire qu'il va couper les ponts
mais un petit peu comme il faut le faire
pour se libérer de les entraves qu'elle
lui avait fait peser pendant toute son
enfance toute son adolescence je pense
que Louis XIV a 22 ans effectivement
décide de se détacher de la tutelle
maternelle et de tout ce qu'il entoure
pour enfin avoir le destin du pays et le
sien de manière totalement autonome
maintenant Louis XIV est seul maître à
bord et peut faire ce que bon lui semble
quitte à provoquer le scandale